la ville de montréal veut redonner vie
au centre-ville qui est presque désert
depuis le début de la pandémie
la ville va consacrer 400 mille dollars
pour aménager et animer le centre-ville
dans l'espoir d'y ramener des visiteurs
c'est de l'argent qui servira notamment
à aménager cette grande terrasse et
places publiques extérieures à compter
du 31 juillet il ya plus de 150 artistes
qui offriront des prestations surprise
soit des performances musicales
théâtrales des numéros de cirque
également l'objectif c'est d'aider les
commerces à survivre à cette crise
c'est catastrophique pour les
commerçants parce que ils ont ouvert ils
ont des frais mais les clients sont
juste pas là j'ai évoqué des restaurants
qui me disaient qu'ils font facilement
60 70 couverts le midi
habituellement et là ils en feront 3/4
des boutiques qui reçoivent en fin de
journée jusqu'à 300 clients et qui
finalement en reçoivent une dizaine à la
fin de la journée
donc c'est très difficile pour nous en
parler on reçoit la mairesse de montréal
valérie plantes
madame plantes merci beaucoup d'être là
cela me fait plaisir est ce que vous
croyez que votre initiative va vraiment
permettre de limiter les dégâts on
espère sauver en partie la période
estivale à montréal oui tout à fait mais
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'éléments qui
permettrait si on veut le dos de sauver
ou du moins de donner un bon coup de
pouce aux commerçants et au centre-ville
de montréal
mais disons que la ville agit là où elle
peut agir alors j'ai pas de contrôle sur
les chiffres en asie avec la santé
publique sur la pandémie par exemple ou
encore le taux d'occupation des tours à
bureaux ont c'est présentement le
gouvernement du québec a choisi souhaite
que ce soit 25% mais alors là mais de
morel on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on fait
ce qu'on attend les bras croisés ou bien
on essaie de stimuler
le stimuler la envie de venir dans le
centre-ville alors on se met à
travailler avec le partenariat du
quartier des spectacles tourisme
montréal et la chambre de commerce du
montréal métropolitain pour faire une
programmation pour venir animer
centre-ville pour que les gens et on dit
envie de venir faire un tour
ouais à quoi ça va servir exactement ces
quatre cent mille dollars c'est pour
aménager les espaces urbains c'est pour
embaucher des artistes oui entre autres
choses engager des artistes je pense que
de ce temps ci les artistes en ont bien
besoin de contrat alors on va leur
demander sa main dans différentes
disciplines de venir animer la rue
d'être à certaines certaines
intersections
on va animer également des placettes et
bien sûr on est toujours en mode
d'accommoder le de faciliter
l'installation des terrasses pour les
restaurateurs et les bars quoique ça
c'est déjà pas mal fait sur sainte
catherine mais on essaie vraiment de
penser à l'extérieur de la boîte et on a
vu que dans d'autres quartiers à
montréal que ce soit sur l'avenue du
mont royal ou encore la rue wellington
le fait de laisser de la place aux
piétons et d'animer ou encore de faire
des murales au sol comme on l'a vu dans
village mais ça donne envie aux gens de
venir fréquenter leurs artères
commerciales locales tout en respectant
la distanciation
oui justement qui souhaitait vous
attirez madame plantes parce que ce
qu'on vise les montréalais et des
québécois évidemment pas les touristes
internationaux mais est-ce qu'on va
dégarnir un quartier pour venir en aide
à un autre non je pense pas je pense une
offre qui est assez complémentaire les
gens moi je me promène beaucoup sur les
artères commerciales locales et les gens
disent qu'ils viennent je leur demande
d'où ils viennent quand jazz avec les
citoyens on me dit quand on vient d'un
autre quartier on est venu pour la
piétonnisation n'a envie de voir de quoi
ça a l'air j'ai des gens qui disent j'ai
pris la piste cyclable ça m'a amené dans
tel ou tel quartier
donc cette ce projet pour la la le
centre-ville de montréal ça touche les
montréalais et montréalaises
les gens de la banlieue mais également
de tout le québec qui pourrait avoir
envie de quitter seulement bon mais
qu'est-ce qu'on prenne un faire d'ici la
fin de l'été alors il pourrait choisir
montréal
d'ailleurs tiens à dire que cette
initiative là commence cette semaine
vont durer jusqu'à la mi octobre alors
osons qu'on étire l'été oui le redis a
déjà des gens on est déjà dans la
semaine des vacances de la construction
il ya bien des gens qui ont déjà leurs
projets de vacances qu'ils ont choisie
parce qu'elle va peut-être moins
d'actions à montréal d'aller ailleurs
d'aller dans les grands espaces est-ce
que ça arrive un peu tard ce plan-là je
cacherai pas cette année c'est très
chamboulée à montréal puisqu'on ville
était au son des festivals des
différentes des restaurants des bars de
toute cette animation vient vivre
montréal les gens qui est visité
montréal mais il veut le sentir la ville
battre et là c'est sûr qu'on est plus au
ralenti étant donné qu'ils ont été
fortement touchés donc je dirais que ça
faisait quand même un bouton qu'on
travaillait sur ce projet pour le centre
ville on attend toujours des sommes
d'argent du provincial et du fédéral qui
ne devrait pas tarder on a quand même
décidé de lancer aujourd'hui justement
pour envoyer le message aux gens si vous
reste des débats consacrés aux
montréalais et montréalaises prévoyez de
venir dans les prochains jours les
prochaines semaines parce qu'il va y
avoir de l'action dans le centre-ville
il va avoir des surprises et on veut
pouvoir a dit on va vous offrir une
offre culturelle et d'animation qui va
être intéressant
oui vous avez évoqué bon des montants
que vous attendez des gouvernements 400
mille dollars quand même une somme
considérable pour une ville que vous
avez les moyens de débourser ça mais je
vous dirais que un moment donné il faut
faire comme j'ai moi je suis du genre à
rester les bras croisés et devint la
difficulté du centre-ville parce que
contrairement à d'autres artères comme
je le disais il ya moins de gens qui
habitent au centre-ville donc c'est
moins une artère de local
c'est plus de destinations moi je me
suis dit étant donné que la situation
n'est pas facile on doit tenter des
choses on doit penser l'extérieur de la
boîte alors pour moi ça 400 mille
dollars là il est bien investi c'est une
façon aussi d'être avec mes partenaires
et sont nombreux les les commerçants les
associations de commerçants les artistes
les partenaires dont je vous ai parlé
partout dans trop de la chambre de
commerce
et est ce qui me fait extrêmement
plaisir comme et reste de voir à quel
point tout le monde a dit j'embarque on
vend on va trouver des solutions on
l'est notre centre-ville
on est fort à montréal on tient à notre
notre vitalité pour leur montrer qu'on
se laisse pas abattre
alors pour moi c'est une belle nouvelle
évidemment les entreprises les
commerçants veulent veulent des
solutions 76 % des gens du milieu des
affaires sont inquiets de la situation
centre-ville est ce que vous pensez que
votre plan les rassure aujourd'hui il
faut savoir que ce qu'on présente
aujourd'hui c'est un plan estival
ça fait partie du plan de relance mais
ce n'est pas le plan de relance le plan
de relance on l'avait annoncé plus tôt
qu'elle 22 millions pour entre autres
les commerçants on est dirait quelque
chose dont je suis très très fier mais
c'est aussi des projets structurants en
transport en habitations qui sont prêts
à partir qu'on a présenté au
gouvernement pour venir commander un
souffle et l'énergie dans l'économie
montréalaise
alors ça c'est vraiment un plan estival
mais pour moi c'est une façon de montrer
autant aux investisseurs et aux
commerçants et aux montréalais qu'on
n'abandonne pas et qu'on est présent et
qu'on va continuer toutes ont le comme
on le fait pendant la coved d'être
créatif et d'être réactifs à papa ou
négativement mais de de trouver des
solutions bien on va continuer à le
faire
valérie plantes merci beaucoup d'avoir
été là ça me fait plaisir au revoir au
revoir